[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in uh chris sims the popular
chris sims they much talked about chris
sims pro football talk live co-host
former nfl quarterback by the way if
you're going to put out a sizzle reel
of all your great predictions i just let
me know because it's basically every
appearance that you make on this show
okay well you're right i mean that's why
you're the man that's why we're best
buddies
you know you've always given me love and
let me talk about these subjects and
it's not just one answer and i
we move on we get to deep dive into it
and uh
that's why you're you're a legend in my
book there big guy all right how did you
prepare
this list of your top quarterbacks and
and i i was curious about the list
because i don't think you go into detail
of how many are going to be taken in the
first round
right well i i think legitimately the
one
and my list just so everybody is out
there and listen you if you want to hear
my breakdown of everything
my chris sims unbuttoned podcast i did
an hour and a half podcast where i
really got into the nitty-gritty stuff
right
but i legitimately look at all the six
guys zach wilson trevor lawrence
mack jones taylor mond justin fields
and trey lance is having elite traits
and being first-round type
talents trey lance is the guy i look at
that could be
the one who doesn't get into the first
round and not because of his talent
but it is still raw he didn't play
football last year the year before that
it was you know a controlled environment
where
there's a lot of games he only throws
the ball 15 18
times so i think that could scare people
all together
but i think legitimately my top five uh
could all be first round first round
picks what does zack wilson do better
than trevor lawrence
zach wilson um i'm blown away by zack
wilson dan
you know i i look at it and look at and
say this isn't aaron rodgers a patrick
mahomes a brett farvish type
guy you know one he's a more consistent
bullseye deadeye thrower i mean and i
mean that with
you know i love trevor lawrence he's
worthy of the number one pick i know i'm
getting a lot of crap about that i'm not
trying to make this about oh he's not
good there's a lot to love about him
but zach wilson it's just every ball
is a perfect spiral on the money all the
plays that are there to be had for ease
and completions he really never misses
and then it's the plays when there's
nothing there that he is
really special and able to create and
buy time
and make unbelievable plays with his
arm and his ability to deliver the ball
in magician-like ways like a mahomes or
an aaron rodgers
yeah i still go back to the coastal
carolina game i know it's only one game
but what i saw was somebody who got
really frustrated
didn't hold his composure whatsoever and
really
coastal carolina's defense really got
into his head
you know you're not going against
alabama here i know and he let coastal
carolina get into his head
and i always want to see what the
quarterback does after he's thrown the
interception
after you've been sacked sure that was
the one thing that stood out with zach
wilson this past year he's extremely
talented but that bothered me chris
well i hear you he's got tremendous
passion
i always watch the worst game i mean and
i'll say is damn if that's his worst
game
holy cow there was some unreal throws
where i just go listen there's not a lot
of people on the planet that can do some
of that
now they had a good defensive game plan
he wasn't totally on his a
game there's no doubt about that and you
know i don't mind the passion
aspect of it in all that and then you
know you know again i don't know
all of those things behind the scenes
i'm just trying to evaluate what i see
on the football field and even in that
game which was his worst game of the
year
it still was really damn good he made
some throws that they had some drops in
the game and all that
and you know i understand it's coastal
carolina and all that it's not alabama
but he also doesn't have clemson and
alabama's offense and things to help him
out the same way too
we have to remember that uh so you know
the the
the competition thing i hear that a lot
you know well it's not the same
competition
well i understand that but trevor
lawrence got to step on the field in
every game in the acc and they were
clearly the better team it's not even
close
so there is some benefits to having that
as well uh
and you know throwing into tight
coverages or throwing under pressure
you know i don't really care what level
that is oh he's open by an inch man the
guy hits the target
oh it's a tight window oh he hits the
target and
he'll adjust according to yes the speed
might be different in the nfl of course
it'll be greater in all those things but
you know phil sims the josh allen's uh
the joe flaccos the terry bradshaws of
the world they came from schools like
that and ended up doing okay so i don't
go too crazy with that aspect all the
time
what is trevor lawrence missing to me
it's just uh
some refining for me and again i expect
trevor lawrence to be the number one
pick
i don't think he's better than zach
wilson but with jack
jacksonville urban meyer he runs ecology
type
offense i could see you know that's it's
a great fit
let alone trevor lawrence in that region
of the country we know is he's a big
deal
he's a big deal altogether but i think
it's more of just the
consistency of throwing that i looked at
dan that i i didn't expect to see
you know as i turned the film on i knew
i was going to see a lot of awesome
plays and all of that and i really liked
trevor lawrence again
but there were more missed throws and
errant throws
than i expected to see as i started to
go through it
and of course hey his team is really
good and you know they have a special
way of calling a game where
you gotta worry about a screen to atn
you gotta worry as a screen to receiver
and then they fake that and there's
somebody open wide open down the middle
of the field
he's awesome prospect like i said
definitely worthy of the number one pick
i just think zach wilson's are like a
ready to go
nfl system superstar right now you
weren't all in on sam darnold being the
number one quarterback
or you know even the second quarterback
off the board here are the jets at
number two
is this is this a no-brainer
zack wilson's right there for you is
this a no-brainer in your opinion
for chris sims it is i i and and i
i still believe in sam darnold and that
he could be a successful nfl quarterback
you know as i always say to mike floria
you know when you're surrounded by crap
you know you're going to get some crap
on you every now and then and smell like
crap i mean that's just the way it is so
it hasn't always been easy for him
i do think he'll fit that mike lefleur
shanahan system and be able to thrive in
that
but i look at at zac wilson and go
he is the perfect fit for that system he
can be aaron rodgers what you're seeing
to matt lafleur in green bay right now
unbelievable feat quick release really
powerful arm
throws the ball on the run better than
anybody in the draft
so he has all those things and i just
think you know if i'm the jets that
would be the guy i would go with yes
by the way i hear great things about
mike leflore he's matt leflore's brother
and i hear great things about him and
some even hold him in higher regard than
his brother
who is the head coach of the green bay
packers well he's he's he's the real
deal there's no question you know
my buddy kyle shanahan always speaks
really highly of him
he's got a little different personality
than his brother
you know matt up there is a little bit
more uh i don't know
quiet and reserved maybe compared to to
matt
but i i expect the jets with i'm a joe
douglas fan
of course i'm a robert salah fan and
with matt lafleur doing the offense
i if they play this off season right
they're sitting in a pretty position to
where they can turn this team around and
i'd be excited to see what
i'm excited to see what they can do over
the next two years chris sims pro
football talk live co-host the former
nfl quarterback
i had a scout say that it feels like the
analysts
are overthinking justin fields
are we overthinking did you overthink
justin fields
you know i'll i'll say this um
i don't go into this with any
preconceived notions i'm a very
cow casual college football watcher
during the year
you know you know me i'm all in on the
nfl i'm dissecting games and doing all
that
to where i'm not going to sit down all
day saturday and watch every game
i just justin feels again has some elite
traits
first off he's built like cam newton
except he's two two inches shorter
his running is better than i expected
you can legitimately have a
running attack behind justin fields his
arm
is its elite and as far as its power and
his ability to make powerful throws deep
throws and do all of that
but man i think what scares me a little
a little bit dan
is um a lot of open spaces he's thrown
into receivers
it's kind of a one-read guy like hey
this guy oh he's not open
and then he looks to run and sometimes
if that first guy's not open
he can be a little careless with the
ball with what he does after it
and the ultimately the thing that scared
me more than anything
was some of the games where his throwing
kind of fell apart
it like really fell apart there is some
true mechanical issues
that need to be worked on for him to be
a complete nfl passer again the final
four in football this year
it's it's the four best passers in the
game i mean it's brady it's rogers it's
josh allen
it's mahomes the game is still about
that and
that's to where to justin feels it's
gonna come into and i don't get this
benefit
knowing the guy at his pro day can we
see improvements on those things that
you know we see issues with on tape and
all of that
but there's just too many errant throws
and out of the group i talked about
he's the worst short ball thrower in the
in the out of the group too
i mean it's 50 50 on shallow crosses and
and throws to the backs out of the
backfield and all of that so those are
the things that kind of concern me again
i think he's a first round talent
there's a lot of elite there
but that's just where i think it needs
some work are you all in on dak prescott
yes i i mean dak prescott is a top 10
quarterback
i'm not gonna say he's top five but i do
believe he's a top ten quarterback
and he has other intangibles that i
think are special to leading a football
team
so but if you were igm yeah if you were
stephen jones
what would you do with dak prescott
right now
i would i would sign him up i would now
yeah broken ankle long-term 40 million
dollars a year
yeah i you know that's that's where i i
don't worry about the ankle
i mean that injury yeah i don't i don't
know if they'll be a hundred percent
to start the year but you know my
history and knowledge of that
kind of injury is in this day and age
2021
he's gonna be okay and you know we saw
how much they declined he makes more
plays than he gets credit for
you know it's not as sexy as some of the
other quarterbacks as far as when he
moves in the pocket and makes a 20-yard
throw down the middle of the field
it doesn't look as cool as mahomes and
josh allen and those guys
but still the results are there that to
me the thing that i don't know and where
i'm confused about it a little bit is
just
you know how much money is he asking for
i am one of those that's like
just because you're the next guy up on
the contract doesn't mean you get to be
the highest paid guy
and i love him he's part of my twitter
page the the
front thing there i'm a big fan um but
but i also don't want to see him take a
deal that you know
crushes his team and then he can't be
successful that way either and i think
that's where the problem lays there
well the problem is you got a lot of
guys who are overpaid
didn't live up to their contracts in
dallas and now he'll get all the blame
if if you know they aren't successful
and they pay him that money
he's going to get blamed if amari cooper
is not a lead or that defense
acts like it did this past year right uh
would you trade for russell wilson if
you're the bears or the saints the
cowboys or the raiders what
out of those four teams who should
i look at the bears as being the team
that needs to make a move
i mean i can't get behind like we're
going to go with nick foles as a
starting quarterback i can't get behind
that
and you know even of course that doesn't
look like they're going to bring back
mitchell trubisky
but i think of all the teams where i
just go they need it to save their own
jobs
their defense is in a pretty good spot
matt
nagy's never really had the quarterback
he wants to run his system
like i could see them being the biggest
players
for watson or russell wilson when all
said and done that's that's the team
that jumps out to me now you know of
course
what are they going to get back for that
and all that that's got to be worked out
um but but i just feel like russell
wilson in seattle is over
and you know it's it's over either next
year or right now
and it's just the seattle have the guts
to make the move right now and say the
hell with it and let's go on and try to
build you know for another year or two
down the road
if you're the falcons gm you got that
number four
pick you got matt ryan what do you do
i'm gonna ride matt ryan for a little
bit longer i am
you know matt ryan and you correct me if
i'm wrong i think he's going to be what
35
or 36 this year you're right there i i
i look at him and go this day and age
with as
long as the quarterbacks can play they
got a lot of
issues and holes on their roster i would
go with matt ryan plus i think he fits
the system in which arthur smith is
going to run
and what we saw in tennessee with ryan
tannehill that he can really make it
work so
i i would go with matt ryan for a few
more years and maybe two three years
from now you start to think about
drafting that next quarterback i think
matt ryan 36th and turns 36 in the
spring pulling that's right
okay okay yeah yeah uh keep stirring it
up chris
did you know me i'm not here to stir it
up i'm not here to stir it up i i have
aspirations to be
pro personnel work in the nfl one day
maybe 10 years down the road
anybody reached out to you about being
in a front office
um i've had dabbles i've had little
dabbles
and just people like are you interested
in this in the next few years and doing
that
um so did you send the sizzle reel send
your hype video
from this show well my first interview
it's it's gonna be a part of that
whenever i get to that i'm gonna you
know i might bring you in with me so you
can just be my hype man
in the corner and we can we can work on
that owner but
you know i'm not here to this drives me
crazy people think i'm here to get
clickbait
and crap like that i'm more into being
right i like to be right more than than
click bait i don't give a damn about
social media so uh i work at it as you
know
i'm not always right but i've been a
right a good amount of times too and
we'll we'll see where this goes the dan
intro over there cheering
like yeah let's go yeah i don't give a
damn about social media yeah yeah
yeah yeah it drives me crazy it drives
me crazy social media i haven't looked
really in the last 24 hours i
i haven't i'm guessing clemson fans are
probably not gonna be too kind to you
oh i i have heard uh you know from the
people who
helped me manage my social media clemson
ohio state
fans uh are are pretty pissed off at me
right now yes
but you're huge in utah
yeah i bet you i am huge in utah you're
right big time i'm a star there all the
way
yeah thank you chris thank you dan be
good man that's chris sims pro football
talk live co-host
the former nfl quarterback and his
quarterbacking rankings
certainly got some attention that's for
sure